This is 99% Invisible. I'm Christopher Johnson filling in this week for Roman Mars. In the mid-1970s, the national media was reporting on the rise of a new socioeconomic group that was quickly gaining unprecedented access to jobs, education, backyard swimming pools, the good life. Journalists seemed fixated on what many were calling the, quote, new black middle class. Black families have entered the mainstream of American life in larger numbers than ever before in our history. No one of them is exceptional, but their total story is. The media's obsession at the time was with how, for this one section of Black America,
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是克里斯托弗·约翰逊，本周代班罗曼·马尔斯。20世纪70年代中期，全国性媒体开始报道一个新兴社会经济群体的崛起，他们正以前所未有的速度获得工作、教育、后院游泳池以及美好生活。记者们似乎对许多人所称的“新黑人中产阶级”着了迷。黑人家庭正以前所未有的规模进入美国主流生活。他们中的每一个人或许并不出众，但他们的整体故事却非同寻常。当时媒体痴迷于这样一个事实：对于这部分美国黑人来说，
the protests and violence of the 1960s seemed to be cross-fading into quiet middle-class achievement. Nowhere near as exciting as a riot or a burning is the move into middle-income America. But this is what Black Americans are achieving more than ever before. In August 1973, Ebony magazine had its own special issue all about the black middle class. On the cover, there was a fisheye photo of an anonymous black man wearing a crisp suit with a tight afro and a briefcase walking through the city with purpose. The stars of the moment were regular, ascendant Black Americans. We were dealing with people that were having economic stability for the first time in generations.
60年代的抗议和暴力似乎正在淡出，取而代之的是安静的中产阶级成就。搬进中产阶级美国的生活，远没有骚乱或纵火那样令人兴奋。但这正是美国黑人比以往任何时候都更努力实现的。1973年8月，《乌木》杂志出版了一期关于黑人中产阶级的特刊。封面上是一张鱼眼镜头拍摄的照片，一位不知名的黑人男子穿着干练的西装，留着紧致的爆炸头，提着公文包，目标明确地走在城市中。那一刻的明星是那些普通的、正在崛起的美国黑人。我们面对的是一群几代人以来首次获得经济稳定的人。
This is writer and cultural critic Craig Seymour. Although there'd always been some version of the Black middle class, Craig says this group of Black Americans was different. The Black middle class of the 70s was really reaching the world with arms wide open and trying to have new opportunities and new experiences that have just not been afforded to masses of Black people before that. And as these new masses were figuring out what upward mobility felt like, they were also exploring what Black middle-classness sounded like.
这位是作家兼文化评论家克雷格·西摩。虽然黑人中产阶级一直存在，但克雷格说，这群美国黑人与众不同。70年代的黑人中产阶级真正张开双臂拥抱世界，试图获得以前从未向广大黑人群众开放的新机会和新体验。当这些新群体开始感受向上流动的滋味时，他们也在探索黑人中产阶级听起来应该是什么样的。
It was the aspiration to expand, to seek out new type of sounds, kind of have new sonic adventures. That's the type of thing that was so different. In the previous decade, some of the biggest songs in Black popular music had been dance-y, sometimes political, and heavy on the funk. Like James Brown's Black Power Anthem, Say It Loud, I'm Black and I'm Proud. This song was a good time with a strong message.
这是一种扩张的渴望，去寻找新的声音，进行某种新的声音冒险。这就是那种非常不同的东西。在过去十年里，黑人流行音乐中最热门的歌曲大多是舞曲风格，有时带有政治色彩，且充满放克味。比如詹姆斯·布朗的黑人权力赞歌《大声说出来，我是黑人，我以此为荣》。这首歌既让人享受，又传达了强有力的信息。
Say it loud, I say it loud. One more time, say it loud. I say it loud. But by the mid-1970s, that new generation of Black Americans was gravitating to a much more mellow sound, a sound that matched the soft life of their middle-class dreams. They wanted music that was smooth and easy and all about love and romance. And at a small Black college radio station in Washington, D.C., a show called The Quiet Storm would give them exactly what they were looking for. Welcome to The Quiet Storm, four hours of my favorite songs presented for your enjoyment.
大声说出来，我大声说出来。再来一次，大声说出来。我大声说出来。但到了70年代中期，那一代新的美国黑人开始倾向于一种更柔和的声音，一种与他们中产阶级梦想中的安逸生活相匹配的声音。他们想要平滑、轻松、充满爱与浪漫的音乐。在华盛顿特区的一家小型黑人大学广播电台，一个名为《宁静风暴》的节目正好满足了他们的需求。欢迎收听《宁静风暴》，为您呈现四小时我最喜爱的歌曲，供您欣赏。
Relax and enjoy The Quiet Storm. The concept of The Quiet Storm radio show was pretty straightforward, an evening program featuring hours of mostly uninterrupted soulful ballads and love songs. That simple format made the Quiet Storm an overnight sensation. And as the show became a fixture in homes and on car stereos throughout Black DC, it also set off a debate over how Black music should sound and what it should say. In the early 1970s, before the Quiet Storm radio show was created, Washington, D.C. was an epicenter of black middle class life. The city was experiencing new levels of black access to good jobs and higher education.
放松心情，享受《宁静风暴》。《宁静风暴》广播节目的概念非常直观：一个晚间节目，播放数小时几乎不间断的深情民谣和情歌。这种简单的形式使《宁静风暴》一夜成名。随着该节目成为华盛顿特区黑人家庭和汽车音响中的常客，它也引发了一场关于黑人音乐应该听起来如何以及应该表达什么的辩论。20世纪70年代初，在《宁静风暴》广播节目诞生之前，华盛顿特区是黑人中产阶级生活的中心。这座城市正在经历黑人获得好工作和高等教育的新阶段。
D.C. was nicknamed the Chocolate City, a town full of black socialites, politicians, and professionals. You had affluent middle-class black folks that liked to go out and party, that had homes. Deanna Williams worked as a DJ in Washington. It was a thriving community of all kind of social economic but black, very very blackity black black and we were thriving. And then the Mecca of all
华盛顿特区被称为“巧克力之城”，是一个充满黑人名流、政客和专业人士的城镇。这里有富裕的中产阶级黑人，他们喜欢外出聚会，拥有自己的房产。迪安娜·威廉姆斯曾在华盛顿担任DJ。那是一个繁荣的社区，各种社会经济背景的人都有，但都是黑人，非常非常纯粹的黑人，我们当时正处于鼎盛时期。而在所有
the HBCUs, Howard University. Oh my goodness. Howard got a new radio station in 1971 and renamed it with its own call letters, WHUR, which stood for Howard University Radio. This was the first black-owned radio station in D.C., a city where three out of four residents were black. Even though WHUR was technically a commercial outlet, it had a strong grassroots feel. There was a news department, blocks of cultural programming, and lots of music. And not just the up-tempo R&B or funky dance music you might hear on other stations, but also roots reggae, Chicago blues, and freedom songs. Deanna Williams was one of WHUR's first DJs.
历史黑人学院（HBCU）的麦加——霍华德大学。天哪。霍华德在1971年拥有了一个新的广播电台，并以其呼号“WHUR”重新命名，代表“霍华德大学广播”。这是华盛顿特区第一家由黑人拥有的广播电台，而这座城市四分之三的居民都是黑人。尽管WHUR在技术上是一家商业电台，但它有着浓厚的草根气息。它设有新闻部、大段的文化节目和大量的音乐。不仅是你可能在其他电台上听到的快节奏R&B或放克舞曲，还有根源雷鬼、芝加哥蓝调和自由之歌。迪安娜·威廉姆斯是WHUR的第一批DJ之一。
She had a show called Ebony Moonbeams. I would come on, you know, this is Deanna Williams, Ebony Moonbeams on 96.3 WHUR, and tonight I've got some special things for you. Like the other DJs, Deanna had eclectic tastes and the freedom to play mostly whatever she wanted. It was freestyle. You heard it all. You heard jazz, you heard gospel. You heard the beauty of us.
她有一个节目叫《乌木月光》。我会上台说，你知道，我是迪安娜·威廉姆斯，在96.3 WHUR收听《乌木月光》，今晚我为你准备了一些特别的东西。和其他DJ一样，迪安娜有着兼收并蓄的品味，并且可以自由播放她想播放的任何音乐。那是自由风格。你什么都能听到。你听到了爵士乐，听到了福音音乐。你听到了我们自身的美丽。
360 degrees of the black experience is what we did. But this kind of programming was not bringing in a lot of money. So just a few years after WHUR first went on the air, Howard's president, James Cheek, started pushing the station to focus more on raising revenue. James Cheek started pushing the station to focus more on raising revenue. Management had a new mandate, which, as one historian put it, was to pursue an upscale commercial niche in the FM market. Basically, they wanted a more bougie audience. Dr. Cheek offered me the opportunity to first become the sales manager of Howard University Radio. As part of that new mission, WHUR hired a woman named Kathy Hughes.
我们所做的是360度全方位的黑人体验。但这种节目并没有带来多少收入。因此，在WHUR开播仅几年后，霍华德大学校长詹姆斯·奇克就开始推动电台专注于增加收入。詹姆斯·奇克开始推动电台专注于增加收入。管理层有了一个新的任务，正如一位历史学家所言，即在调频市场中追求一个高端商业利基市场。基本上，他们想要一个更“布尔乔亚”的受众。奇克博士给了我机会，让我先成为霍华德大学广播电台的销售经理。作为新使命的一部分，WHUR聘请了一位名叫凯西·休斯的女士。
Here's Kathy in an interview with KUT Radio in 2020. I was blessed my first year, increased the ratings and the revenue substantially. In 1975, when Kathy was just 28 years old, she became the first woman to run a broadcast facility in the nation's capital. And she would soon reshape the station in ways that would ripple through black music and radio for the next decade. She did it by focusing on a new target audience, DC's young, thriving black middle class. Kathy Hughes was incredibly savvy about understanding how radio audiences worked, how to sell airtime, but also how to program certain types of music to specific audiences. Music critic Eric Harvey has written about WHUR's history, and he says, as Kathy was
这是凯西在2020年接受KUT电台采访时的片段。我很幸运，第一年就大幅提高了收视率和收入。1975年，年仅28岁的凯西成为全国首都第一位管理广播设施的女性。她很快将以一种在未来十年里影响黑人音乐和广播的方式重塑该电台。她通过专注于一个新的目标受众——华盛顿特区年轻、繁荣的黑人中产阶级——做到了这一点。凯西·休斯非常精明，了解广播受众的运作方式、如何销售广告时段，以及如何为特定受众编排特定类型的音乐。音乐评论家埃里克·哈维撰写过关于WHUR历史的文章，他说，当凯西
thinking about how to make music shows to attract new listeners to the station, she decided to survey the people closest to her. You know, she was looking at her girlfriends. Who was she hanging out with? Upwardly mobile, single, black women who were being completely underserved by popular radio. From her focus group, Kathy realized that a local show that appealed to single black women, especially professional black women, could be really popular
思考如何制作音乐节目以吸引新听众时，她决定调查身边的人。你知道，她观察着她的闺蜜们。她和谁在一起？那些向上流动的、单身的黑人女性，她们在流行广播中完全被忽视了。通过焦点小组，凯西意识到，一个吸引单身黑人女性，尤其是职业黑人女性的本地节目，可能会非常受欢迎，
and a great source of ad revenue. Kathy began to loosely conceive of a weekend evening show focused on romantic music, slow soulful R&B ballads, and very smooth love songs. She knew that there were a lot of single young black women in the DC area. This is writer and cultural critic, Craig Seymour, again. So she thought, well, hey, who doesn't want to be serenaded?
并且成为广告收入的巨大来源。凯西开始构思一个周末晚间节目，专注于浪漫音乐、缓慢深情的R&B民谣和非常柔和的情歌。她知道华盛顿地区有很多单身年轻黑人女性。这是作家兼文化评论家克雷格·西摩再次发言。所以她想，嘿，谁不想被小夜曲打动呢？
You know, who doesn't want to have somebody play love songs to them and talk in a deep voice and listen to that. So she kind of tailored the show to that particular audience. One version of the show's origin story, and there are a few, is that Cathy had a bit of a tough time finding the right DJ to host the show. She eventually settled on an intern named Melvin Lindsey, who also babysat her son.
你知道，谁不想有人为他们播放情歌，用低沉的声音说话，并聆听这些呢？所以她为那个特定的受众量身定制了这个节目。关于节目起源的一个版本（当然还有其他版本）是，凯西在寻找合适的DJ来主持节目时遇到了一些困难。她最终选定了一位名叫梅尔文·林赛的实习生，他当时还负责照顾她的儿子。
Although Melvin was not Cathy's first or favorite choice for the DJ gig, he was the one who would soon take her idea and make it a huge success. Melvin was a handsome, button-down kid from D.C., known for carrying a briefcase around campus. He could also be super shy. Deanna Williams was one of Melvin's mentors at WHUR. Melvin was still a student when I was on the radio. He was very quiet until he got comfortable.
虽然梅尔文不是凯西担任DJ的首选或最爱，但他很快将她的想法变成了巨大的成功。梅尔文是一个来自华盛顿的英俊、穿着考究的孩子，以在校园里随身携带公文包而闻名。他有时也会非常害羞。迪安娜·威廉姆斯是梅尔文在WHUR的导师之一。我在电台工作时，梅尔文还是个学生。他非常安静，直到他感到自在为止。
And that quietness is what set Melvin apart immediately, the night he hosted his first show in May 1976. That's because Melvin represented a new kind of on-air personality. The previous generation of black radio DJs were super performative, flamboyant, and kind of rambunctious. Rock-a-chip time one more time and look out y'all, cause here we go! How about that now? Let's continue on with more recorded music.
正是那种安静让梅尔文在1976年5月主持第一场节目时脱颖而出。这是因为梅尔文代表了一种新型的广播个性。上一代黑人广播DJ非常具有表演性、浮夸且有些吵闹。再来一次摇滚时间，小心了，我们要开始了！现在怎么样？让我们继续播放更多录制好的音乐。
K-C-O-H! Melvin mellowed that profile way out. When he spoke, ugh, pure satin. Melvin was so gentle and fluid, and it all seemed just effortless. The next couple of songs I'm gonna play have a lot of meaning for me and I want you to listen to the words. They're dedicated from me to you
K-C-O-H！梅尔文把那种风格变得非常柔和。当他说话时，噢，纯粹如丝绸般顺滑。梅尔文是如此温柔和流畅，一切看起来都毫不费力。接下来的几首歌对我来说意义重大，我希望你们仔细听歌词。这是我献给你们的，
and then I'll be back to say something else before I go, but listen to these, they're just for you. ["Warm Inviting Engaging"] Warm, inviting, engaging, that was his style. His style of radio, it made you feel like he was talking directly to you. That's a big achievement to be able to do that as a radio personality. He had the voice, he had the composure, he was humble. It was like a chef. Like he prepared this great soul-satisfying meal.
之后我会回来再说点别的，但在我离开之前，听听这些，它们只属于你。["温暖、迷人、引人入胜"] 温暖、迷人、引人入胜，这就是他的风格。他的广播风格让你觉得他是在直接和你对话。作为一名广播主持人，能做到这一点是一项了不起的成就。他有嗓音，有风度，而且谦逊。他就像一位厨师。他准备了一顿令人灵魂满足的盛宴。
WHUR had never done a show that sounded like this. Up to that point, the station was mostly a mix of public affairs programming and a lot of jazz. Definitely not B-side baby making music. Listeners were caught totally off guard. On the night of the first broadcast, Melvin was flooded with calls from people requesting their own favorite slow jams. Others phoned in just to show the young DJ some love. For the next two days, WHUR Switchboard lit up with listeners calling in from all over the DC area,
WHUR从未做过听起来像这样的节目。在那之前，该电台大多是公共事务节目和大量爵士乐的混合体。绝对不是那种适合亲热的B面音乐。听众完全被打了个措手不及。在第一次广播的那天晚上，梅尔文接到了无数听众的电话，要求播放他们自己最喜欢的慢歌。其他人打电话进来只是为了给这位年轻的DJ一些爱。接下来的两天里，WHUR的交换机亮个不停，来自华盛顿地区各地的听众打来电话，
asking about that new show. Together, Kathy Hughes and Melvin Lindsey, the intern student babysitter, had just created a hit. Here's Melvin in 1991, talking about how the show just took off. It started out of love, out of fun, out of people putting their heads together,
询问那个新节目。凯西·休斯和梅尔文·林赛——那个实习生、学生、保姆——刚刚创造了一个热门节目。这是梅尔文在1991年谈论节目如何起飞的片段。它始于爱，始于乐趣，始于人们齐心协力，
and not even realizing that we were really creating such a monster in the radio industry. But the program still needed a name. About a year before the show first went on the air, Smokey Robinson had released a comeback album full of love songs titled A Quiet Storm, which featured the extremely sensual, suggestive hit single of the same name. Quiet Storm
甚至没有意识到我们真的在广播行业创造了一个庞然大物。但节目仍然需要一个名字。在节目开播前大约一年，斯莫基·罗宾逊发行了一张充满情歌的复出专辑，名为《宁静风暴》，其中收录了同名且极具感官诱惑力的热门单曲。《宁静风暴》
Blowing through my life Kathy told Melvin they should name their show The Quiet Storm. She said the phrase had, quote, subliminal seduction in it, which was exactly the feel she wanted for her program. Naturally, Melvin used Smokey's track as the show's theme song. Good evening, I'm Melvin Lindsay and welcome to The Quiet Storm. Again, I want to thank everyone from WHUR's news department, the entire staff here. They've been so good to me. The Quiet Storm show started in 1976, and by the end of the next year, it was the number one
吹过我的生命。凯西告诉梅尔文，他们应该把节目命名为《宁静风暴》。她说这个短语有一种“潜意识的诱惑”，这正是她想要的节目感觉。自然地，梅尔文使用了斯莫基的曲目作为节目的主题曲。晚上好，我是梅尔文·林赛，欢迎收听《宁静风暴》。再次感谢WHUR新闻部的每一个人，以及这里的全体员工。他们对我太好了。《宁静风暴》节目始于1976年，到第二年年底，它已成为华盛顿排名第一的
weekend music show in Washington. The show was so successful, Cathy expanded it to weeknights, which made WHUR the second highest rated FM station in DC. And it brought in millions in ad sales for the station. The Quiet Storm's sudden and wild popularity came in part thanks to Melvin's innovation as a curator. Instead of going for the up-tempo jams, he chose softer tracks,
周末音乐节目。该节目非常成功，凯西将其扩展到了工作日晚上，这使得WHUR成为华盛顿收视率第二高的调频电台。它为电台带来了数百万的广告销售额。 《宁静风暴》突然且狂热的流行，部分归功于梅尔文作为策展人的创新。他没有选择快节奏的歌曲，而是选择了更柔和的曲目，
the Smooth Soul, the Romantic Ballads, and much of it was new music by black artists like Gene Carnes, You Are All I Need, and LTD's sumptuous, perfectly titled track, Love Ballad. And what we have is much more than they could see And they'll never ever, never, never, so much more have As a grassroots-oriented station, WHUR had its own history of free-form programming, where DJs just kind of let the music sprawl.
平滑的灵魂乐、浪漫的民谣，其中大部分是黑人艺术家的新音乐，如吉恩·卡恩斯的《你就是我所需要的一切》，以及LTD那首华丽、标题完美的曲目《爱情民谣》。而我们所拥有的远比他们所能看到的要多，他们永远永远，永远永远，拥有更多。作为一家以草根为导向的电台，WHUR有其自己的自由形式节目历史，DJ们只是让音乐自然流淌。
Melvin and Cathy's innovation was the way they took that free-form approach and applied it to a new kind of music, slow jam deep cuts. Throughout the day's programming, starting with morning drive until afternoon drive, you got music that was keeping you up, going, more up tempo music, but then that stopped when it got dark and you were not working and you were not driving. You had finished dinner and homework with the kids and you were not working and you were not driving, you had finished dinner and homework with the kids, and you were lighting your candle and maybe more and chilling.
梅尔文和凯西的创新在于他们将这种自由形式的方法应用到了一种新的音乐类型上：慢歌深层曲目。在全天的节目中，从早高峰到晚高峰，你听到的音乐让你保持清醒、充满活力，节奏更快，但当夜幕降临，你不再工作、不再开车时，那种音乐就停止了。你吃完了晚饭，帮孩子们做完了作业，你不再工作、不再开车，你吃完了晚饭，帮孩子们做完了作业，你点上了蜡烛，也许还有更多，开始放松。
And so what you were hearing were mid-tempo and ballads that were about love. Music critic Craig Seymour remembers how, as a kid, he and his mother would sit in the car outside their home, listening to the quiet storm, completely immersed. And we would wait until the commercial break, and then go inside the house and turn on the radio while the commercial break was on, because you just really wouldn't want to miss these songs,
所以你听到的是关于爱的中速歌曲和民谣。音乐评论家克雷格·西摩记得，小时候，他和母亲会坐在家门外的车里，听着《宁静风暴》，完全沉浸其中。我们会等到广告时间，然后走进屋里，在广告期间打开收音机，因为你真的不想错过这些歌，
because you really had no other chance to hear many of them. These weren't hits now. They were really rare cuts, deep cuts, and unique to him and his taste. Melvin really seized on a major shift that was happening in Black music in the late 1960s and early 70s. In that moment of arms-wide open exploration, Black groups were experimenting with a whole new kind of sound. It starts with the artists making these, I don't want to say slicker in a bad way, but just kind of these more sophisticated, musically sophisticated type of popular music. Sophisticated. That's how several critics have described this evolution, as popular soul and R&B started to expand from the shorter, more jerky dance funk tunes
因为你真的没有其他机会听到其中的许多歌曲。这些现在不是热门歌曲。它们是非常罕见的曲目，深层曲目，对他和他的品味来说是独一无二的。梅尔文确实抓住了20世纪60年代末和70年代初黑人音乐中发生的一个重大转变。在那一刻张开双臂的探索中，黑人团体正在尝试一种全新的声音。这始于艺术家们制作这些——我不想说“更圆滑”是一个贬义词，但只是那种更精致、音乐上更复杂的流行音乐。精致。这就是几位评论家描述这种演变的方式，因为流行灵魂乐和R&B开始从上一代更短、更跳跃的放克舞曲中扩展开来。
of the previous era. Artists were smoothing the edges, making songs longer, and bedazzling their tracks with big, rich string sections. This modern, elegant, soft, romantic edge to popular soul music that artists were expanding upon in the early 1970s. And you can look at what Isaac Hayes was beginning to do.
艺术家们正在磨平棱角，使歌曲更长，并用宏大、丰富的弦乐部分来装饰他们的曲目。这种现代、优雅、柔和、浪漫的流行灵魂乐边缘，是艺术家们在20世纪70年代初所扩展的。你可以看看艾萨克·海耶斯开始做的事情。
Lush orchestrations for big concept albums with very romantic themes. You have Isaac Hayes doing, you know doing these long instrumental tracks. Barry White. All these things are about that are starting to happen along with black music soundtracks. This is music and culture critic Nelson George. He says one thing that was driving this expansiveness was the influence of soundtracks for black themed films like Shaft, Trouble Man, and Sparkle. This was beautiful, innovative music
为具有非常浪漫主题的大型概念专辑进行华丽的编曲。你有艾萨克·海耶斯在做，你知道，在做这些长篇器乐曲目。巴里·怀特。所有这些事情都在发生，伴随着黑人音乐原声带。这是音乐和文化评论家尼尔森·乔治。他说，推动这种扩张的一件事是黑人主题电影（如《夏福特》、《麻烦人》和《星光》）原声带的影响。这是美丽、创新的音乐，
that adapted funk and soul to the openness, continuity, and minor key moodiness of film scoring. For example, songs like Curtis Mayfield's Give Me Your Love from the Superfly soundtrack. Black film soundtracks were having a major influence on R&B. And as more and more artists began replicating the lush, palatial sound of film scores, what emerged was a kind of smooth soul that would help define Quiet Storm. So the music is changing, the ambition, the song, the tracks are getting longer.
将放克和灵魂乐改编为电影配乐的开放性、连续性和小调情绪。例如，像柯蒂斯·梅菲尔德在《超级飞》原声带中的《给我你的爱》这样的歌曲。黑人电影原声带对R&B产生了重大影响。随着越来越多的艺术家开始复制电影配乐中那种华丽、宏伟的声音，一种有助于定义《宁静风暴》的平滑灵魂乐应运而生。所以音乐在改变，野心、歌曲、曲目都在变长。
And so, you know, HUR is one of the stations that was responding to that in terms of what their playlist is and the sound of the station. The Quiet Storm may have been aimed at the black middle class at first, but it quickly transcended. If you walked through any of DC's black neighborhoods in the evening, you could hear the radio show coming out of row house windows and the cars that drove by just as the sun was setting. When the Quiet Storm time came, it's like the tempo just slowed down and it was just,
所以，你知道，HUR是响应这一点的电台之一，就其播放列表和电台声音而言。《宁静风暴》起初可能针对的是黑人中产阶级，但它很快就超越了这一点。如果你在傍晚走过华盛顿特区的任何黑人社区，你都能听到广播节目从排屋的窗户和路过的汽车中传出来，就在太阳落山的时候。《宁静风暴》的时间到了，节奏就像慢了下来，它只是，
it's just so hard to explain the piece. Now that radio culture isn't as big, but just how a show could really just change the vibe of a whole city or at least the black part of the city at a particular time. It's almost like a dimmer switch, you know, where it's like all of a sudden these ballads started coming in and just the whole vibe of Black Washington began to change along with the moods of Melvin Lindsay. And at the time, Black DC was looking to turn down the dimmer switch, not just on the mood, but on life. The quiet storm became so deeply special to Black Washington because this was a moment when folks really needed some quiet.
真的很难解释那种平静。现在广播文化没那么盛行了，但一个节目真的可以改变整个城市，或者至少是城市中黑人部分的氛围，在特定的时间。这几乎就像一个调光开关，你知道，突然间这些民谣开始出现，整个华盛顿黑人区的氛围随着梅尔文·林赛的情绪开始改变。当时，华盛顿的黑人区正寻求调低调光开关，不仅是情绪，还有生活。《宁静风暴》对华盛顿黑人区变得如此特别，因为这是一个人们真正需要安静的时刻。
The movements of the 1950s and 60s had led to historic gains in education, employment, housing and the expansion of Black political and racial self-awareness, all of that. But look at the tremendous costs. The civil rights era had been so violent, so tumultuous, especially in places like D.C. The biggest uprising after Martin Luther King's assassination took place in the heart of black Washington. What that did to the psyche of black people starts to push us into a post-civil rights era of the 1970s. Fredera Hadley is an ethnomusicologist at Julliard.
20世纪50年代和60年代的运动带来了教育、就业、住房和黑人政治及种族自我意识扩展的历史性成果，所有这些。但看看巨大的代价。民权时代太暴力、太动荡了，尤其是在华盛顿特区等地。马丁·路德·金遇刺后最大的起义发生在华盛顿黑人区的中心。这对黑人的心理造成的影响，开始将我们推向20世纪70年代的后民权时代。弗雷德拉·哈德利是朱莉亚音乐学院的民族音乐学家。
And so people start really turning to the future and trying to just imagine what is this we are now entering or creating. This moment of swift change brought up all sorts of existential questions for black folks. As we integrate into a white world, how do we remain Black? What do we do differently? What's still ours? And given how hard white people fought this, are we safe in this new America? Desegregation had been exhausting. Integration and assimilation were exhausting. Some Black folks just needed a moment to catch their collective breath. And Fredera says, the quiet storm provided
所以人们开始真正转向未来，试图想象我们现在正在进入或创造的是什么。这一剧烈变化的时刻为黑人带来了各种各样的存在主义问题。当我们融入白人世界时，我们如何保持黑人身份？我们做什么不同的事情？什么仍然属于我们？考虑到白人对此的激烈反抗，我们在新的美国安全吗？种族隔离的废除令人筋疲力尽。融合和同化令人筋疲力尽。一些黑人只是需要片刻时间来集体喘口气。弗雷德拉说，《宁静风暴》提供了
a soundtrack for that transition. A transition to some semblance of normalcy by way of romance. I think it really takes hold because it is the music of that kind of intimate, deeply personal life. It's not about we shall overcome. It's about you and me or me and mine. It's about feelings. Like, how do I feel about you? How do I feel about us?
那种过渡的配乐。通过浪漫过渡到某种正常状态。我认为它之所以真正扎根，是因为它是那种亲密、极其个人生活的音乐。它不是关于“我们终将克服”。它是关于“你和我”或“我和我的”。它是关于感受。比如，我对你感觉如何？我们对彼此感觉如何？
How do I want you to feel about me, right? In some small but really important ways, Melvin's show helped people to shut out the loudness and intensity and confusion of the world just for a few hours and focus on themselves and their own hearts. This was a time to unplug, to pour a glass of wine, to make dinner for yourself and maybe the ones you love.
我希望你对我感觉如何，对吧？在一些微小但非常重要的方式上，梅尔文的节目帮助人们在几个小时内屏蔽了世界的喧嚣、强度和混乱，专注于他们自己和他们自己的内心。这是一个拔掉插头、倒一杯酒、为自己和也许你爱的人做顿晚餐的时间。
Melvin was skilled and he learned what song is going to get people at this time. This is former WHUR DJ Deanna Williams again. He knew when people were getting home, he knew when people would probably finish dinner, he knew when people were probably getting in bed. So you getting in bed, it's time to get some, you know, get in bed, get down with it music. You know, your mama was listening, you know, your daddy was listening to the Quiet Storm, like I said, that baby making music.
梅尔文技术娴熟，他学会了什么歌在什么时候能打动人。这是前WHUR DJ迪安娜·威廉姆斯再次发言。他知道人们什么时候回家，他知道人们什么时候可能吃完晚饭，他知道人们什么时候可能上床睡觉。所以你上床睡觉了，是时候听点，你知道，上床、沉浸其中的音乐了。你知道，你妈妈在听，你知道，你爸爸在听《宁静风暴》，就像我说的，那是“造人音乐”。
So get in bed, get busy in bed, get busy in the kitchen, whatever. Look, it's easy to snicker about the Quiet Storm, a show full of sappy love songs and sugary ballads about sex. But for Craig Seymour, it was bigger than that. He first discovered The Quiet Storm at a pretty young age, and the show helped him wrestle with some big questions about true romance. It was so much of an education for me because those ballads that Melvin Lindsay played gave me a certain deeper feeling of like wondering what life circumstances would have to happen
所以上床吧，在床上忙活吧，在厨房忙活吧，随便。看，嘲笑《宁静风暴》很容易，一个充满感伤情歌和关于性的甜腻民谣的节目。但对克雷格·西摩来说，它不仅仅是那样。他在很小的时候就发现了《宁静风暴》，这个节目帮助他应对了一些关于真爱的重大问题。这对我来说是一种教育，因为梅尔文·林赛播放的那些民谣给了我一种更深层的感觉，比如想知道生活中会发生什么样的情况，
where you would feel like this, like the way that a singer would sing a particular song. I kind of grappled with the mysteries of adulthood through listening to The Quiet Storm. Specifically, Craig says The Quiet Storm helped him sort through his feelings of love and desire as a gay kid. Craig didn't realize at the time that Melvin Lindsay was also gay. But today, Craig definitely thinks Melvin's musical selections often had double meanings, that he would play certain songs to send messages and tell stories that only his gay listeners could decode. You're kind of faced with these romantic songs
才会让你有这种感觉，就像歌手唱某首歌的方式一样。我通过听《宁静风暴》来应对成年生活的奥秘。具体来说，克雷格说《宁静风暴》帮助他理清了作为一个同性恋孩子对爱和欲望的感受。克雷格当时并没有意识到梅尔文·林赛也是同性恋。但今天，克雷格绝对认为梅尔文的音乐选择往往有双重含义，他会播放某些歌曲来传递信息，讲述只有他的同性恋听众才能解码的故事。你面对的是这些浪漫的歌曲，
about love gained, love lost. When I would try to put myself into those situations, there's a way that I had to confront queerness because, you know, I knew that I wasn't going to be singing You Bring Me Joy, you know, to a woman. But for me, that wasn't scary. It was kind of fascinating and kind of safe to explore the idea of romance in this safe space of the Quiet Storm. Craig and I both grew up in the Washington area in the 1970s and 80s. When I was a little kid,
关于得到的爱，失去的爱。当我试图把自己置身于那些情境中时，我必须面对酷儿身份，因为，你知道，我知道我不会对着一个女人唱《你带给我快乐》。但对我来说，那并不吓人。在《宁静风暴》这个安全的空间里探索浪漫的想法，既迷人又安全。克雷格和我都是在20世纪70年代和80年代在华盛顿地区长大的。当我还是个小孩子时，
my mom would drive me from Silver Spring, Maryland into Northeast D.C. to drop me at my grandma's house near Fort Stevens. As we rode down Georgia Avenue into the evening, past the Safeway and the barbershop in Shepherd Park where I hated going to get my hair cut, I'd stare out the car window. It had been two decades since the King riots, but I could see a lot of the buildings were still boarded up. From the backseat of my mom's Green Ford Granada, I could hear the quiet storm crackling into clarity on the car radio. The music of Marvin Gaye along with Tammy Terrell the year 1967, 724 in Washington once
我妈妈会开车带我从马里兰州的银泉市到华盛顿东北部，把我送到史蒂文斯堡附近的奶奶家。当我们傍晚沿着乔治亚大道行驶，经过西夫韦超市和谢泼德公园里我讨厌去理发的理发店时，我会盯着车窗外看。距离金博士骚乱已经过去二十年了，但我能看到很多建筑仍然用木板封着。坐在妈妈那辆绿色福特格拉纳达的后座上，我能听到《宁静风暴》在车载收音机里清晰地响起。马文·盖伊和塔米·特雷尔的音乐，1967年，华盛顿时间7点24分，再次
again good evening. My mom was a single black woman from DC who worked for the city government not quite middle class but my mother loved love and she sang every song it must have felt like melvin was DJing just for her the music of patty labelle on whur the title tunes her latest album i'm in love Love Again. And before that, it's Patti LaBelle with Since I Don't Have You. Two minutes before 8 p.m., you're listening to The Quiet Storm. By the early 1980s, WHUR's The Quiet Storm had grown into something way bigger than the radio program that Kathy Hughes and Melvin Lindsay started in 1976.
晚上好。我妈妈是一位来自华盛顿的单身黑人女性，在市政府工作，算不上中产阶级，但我妈妈热爱爱情，她唱每一首歌。那一定感觉就像梅尔文专门为她做DJ一样。WHUR播放帕蒂·拉贝尔的音乐，她最新专辑的主打歌《我再次坠入爱河》。在那之前，是帕蒂·拉贝尔的《自从我没有你》。晚上8点前两分钟，你正在收听《宁静风暴》。到20世纪80年代初，WHUR的《宁静风暴》已经发展成比凯西·休斯和梅尔文·林赛在1976年开始的广播节目大得多的东西。
That one local show was now having a big influence on broadcasting across the US. Within 10 years, almost every major market black radio station in the country has a quiet storm. Three to five hours, overnight usually, maybe starting at 11 or midnight. These became a staple. Nelson George wrote a front page story in 1986
那个本地节目现在对全美的广播产生了巨大影响。十年之内，全国几乎每个主要市场的黑人广播电台都有了《宁静风暴》。通常是三到五个小时，在深夜，可能从11点或午夜开始。这些成为了主打节目。尼尔森·乔治在1986年写了一篇头版报道，
for Billboard magazine with the headline, Quiet Storm Sweeps Black Radio. He describes how the DC show had inspired 120 broadcasters around the country to develop their own shows and sometimes even entire stations, just like the WHUR program. Those new shows were not affiliated with the original Quiet Storm but a lot of these copycat programs nodded to it with names like Sunday Night Cool Out and Soft
为《公告牌》杂志撰写，标题是《宁静风暴席卷黑人广播》。他描述了华盛顿的节目如何激励了全国120家广播公司开发他们自己的节目，有时甚至是整个电台，就像WHUR的节目一样。那些新节目与最初的《宁静风暴》没有关联，但许多模仿节目通过像《周日夜冷静》和《柔和触感》这样的名字向它致敬，
Touch and their approach and sound was pretty standard Quiet Storm and the DJs were clearly imitating Melvin's signature smooth style. There's a lot more mellow voices. They tended to be either very low-tone women or low baritone men. It's really a profound aesthetic change. It's going from hard, you know, some whiskey to cognac. So like in New York was Vaughn Harper. Vaughn Harper had a very deep voice.
它们的方法和声音非常标准地模仿了《宁静风暴》，DJ们显然在模仿梅尔文标志性的平滑风格。有更多柔和的声音。它们往往是音调非常低的女性或低男中音男性。这真的是一种深刻的审美改变。就像从烈酒，你知道，威士忌变成了干邑。比如在纽约有沃恩·哈珀。沃恩·哈珀的声音非常深沉。
Welcome to the Quiet Storm. You know, blah, blah, blah, blah. It's 107.5 WBLS four times, and I just can't walk away. Not from you, because you are the spice of life. As Quiet Storm programming took off on black radio in the mid 1980s, the Quiet Storm sound solidified into a brand new genre of music.
欢迎收听《宁静风暴》。你知道，等等等等。现在是107.5 WBLS，四次了，我就是无法走开。不是离开你，因为你是生活的调味品。随着《宁静风暴》节目在80年代中期在黑人广播中兴起，《宁静风暴》的声音固化成了一种全新的音乐流派。
Record companies saw this as a chance to sell a lot of music to the so-called sophisticated Quiet Storm audience with disposable income. And they put pressure on musicians as they went into the studio to record their next albums. Here's music critic Eric Harvey again. Record labels started asking their artists, hey, you know, can we get a song on side B or QuietStorm format? And then we'll, you know, service the other radio stations with the more uptempo kind of pop songs. And here's probably the most impressive sign of just how powerful and influential Quietstorm had become. Quietstorm Radio was launching full superstars.
唱片公司将其视为向所谓的拥有可支配收入的“精致”《宁静风暴》受众销售大量音乐的机会。他们在音乐家进入录音室录制下一张专辑时向他们施压。这是音乐评论家埃里克·哈维再次发言。唱片公司开始问他们的艺术家，嘿，你知道，我们能在B面或《宁静风暴》格式中放一首歌吗？然后我们，你知道，为其他广播电台提供更具快节奏的流行歌曲。这是《宁静风暴》变得多么强大和有影响力的最令人印象深刻的迹象。宁静风暴广播正在推出全明星。
Several legendary artists owe a lot of their stardom to Quietstorm. Not just because of a few songs, these are balladeers who fully embodied that smooth, mellow, romantic sound. Artists like Luther Vandross. who fully embodied that smooth, mellow, romantic sound. Artists like Luther Vandross. ["A House is Not a Home"] Craig Seymour wrote a biography of Luther Vandross and says knockout quiet storm ballads like A House is Not a Home
几位传奇艺术家将他们的明星地位归功于《宁静风暴》。不仅仅是因为几首歌，这些是完全体现了那种平滑、柔和、浪漫声音的民谣歌手。像路德·范德鲁斯这样的艺术家。完全体现了那种平滑、柔和、浪漫的声音。像路德·范德鲁斯这样的艺术家。["家不是一个家"] 克雷格·西摩写了一本关于路德·范德鲁斯的传记，并说像《家不是一个家》这样出色的《宁静风暴》民谣
are what really helped solidify Luther's massive audience. ["A House is Not a Home"] Luther's massive audience. But no one saw more commercial success thanks to Quiet Storm Radio than Anita Baker. Her 1986 album, Rapture, was a Quiet Storm staple, with songs like Same Old Love and You Bring Me Joy. You bring me joy when I'm down At the time, it was rare for a black musician doing adult R&B to have what was called a crossover album, one that went beyond Quiet Storm and other formats that were considered black radio to find success with mainstream, that is, white listeners. But that's exactly what happened with Rapture.
是真正帮助巩固路德庞大受众的原因。["家不是一个家"] 路德庞大的受众。但没有人比安妮塔·贝克从《宁静风暴》广播中获得更多的商业成功。她1986年的专辑《狂喜》是《宁静风暴》的主打，收录了像《老调重弹》和《你带给我快乐》这样的歌曲。当你低落时，你带给我快乐。当时，黑人音乐家做成人R&B拥有所谓的“跨界”专辑（即超越《宁静风暴》和其他被认为是黑人广播的格式，在主流即白人听众中获得成功）是罕见的。但这正是《狂喜》所发生的情况。
The album was launched by Quiet Storm Radio and then crossed over to Pop Radio, expanding Anita Baker's audience exponentially. I mean, the song Sweet Love, you know, it reached the Billboard Top 10. It crossed over to pop audiences and it started in the Quiet Storm rotation. Sweet love, he'll make your heart ring out your love. I threw those shit bombs out of your mouth. To this day, Anita Baker can still sell out, you know, 5,000 seat theaters, and it's hard to imagine
这张专辑由《宁静风暴》广播推出，然后跨界到流行广播，使安妮塔·贝克的受众呈指数级增长。我的意思是，歌曲《甜蜜的爱》，你知道，它进入了《公告牌》前十名。它跨界到了流行受众，并且始于《宁静风暴》的轮播。甜蜜的爱，他会让你的心鸣响你的爱。我把那些狗屎炸弹从你嘴里扔了出去。直到今天，安妮塔·贝克仍然可以卖光，你知道，5000座的剧院，很难想象
Anita Baker's stardom being half of what it is today without being nurtured in the quiet storm format. Coming up, not everyone was into these smooth baby-making vibes. The Quiet Storm backlash smooth, pop soul, love song sound was blowing up on radio stations and in record stores all over the country. But not everyone was feeling the love. There were lots of aesthetic criticisms about Quiet Storm music, which, you know, in some cases was deserved.
如果没有在《宁静风暴》格式中得到培养，安妮塔·贝克的明星地位会是今天的一半。接下来，并非每个人都喜欢这些平滑的“造人”氛围。《宁静风暴》的反弹。平滑、流行灵魂乐、情歌的声音在全国各地的广播电台和唱片店中爆炸。但并非每个人都感受到了爱。关于《宁静风暴》音乐有很多审美批评，你知道，在某些情况下是应得的。
First of all, music critic Eric Harvey says some music fans complained that Quiet Storm music wasn't really music at all. More like mushy, tuneless versions of Black America's great funk, jazz, and soul traditions. This is music that could easily be called by some critics, you know, sonic wallpaper, easy listening. And in a way, the detractors were right. Part of the point of Quiet Storm was that it was music that wasn't necessarily so rich. You could just vibe. So one of the features that was making Quiet Storm so popular
首先，音乐评论家埃里克·哈维说，一些音乐迷抱怨《宁静风暴》音乐根本不是音乐。更像是美国黑人伟大的放克、爵士和灵魂乐传统的糊状、无调版本。这是可以被一些评论家轻易称为，你知道，声音壁纸、轻音乐的音乐。在某种程度上，批评者是对的。《宁静风暴》的部分意义在于它不是那种必然非常丰富的音乐。你只是可以享受氛围。所以使《宁静风暴》如此受欢迎的特征之一
in the mid-80s was the very thing it was getting dragged for at the exact same time. This is music that is designed in a certain way to blend in with other activities, making dinner, having a glass of wine, making out, etc. etc. And, you know, for some people, it's like what you listen to over the PA system at the mall. Even harsher, if you can imagine, was the critique that Quiet Storm was so decidedly apolitical. And to some, that was unusual for a form of black music as big and influential as Quiet Storm. With more than a hint of shade, one critic even described Anita Baker as of saying that African Americans have succeeded in making it to the middle class, like we're just going to listen to this kind of soft complacent sounding
在80年代中期，正是它同时受到抨击的原因。这是以某种方式设计来融入其他活动的音乐，做晚饭、喝杯酒、亲热等等等等。而且，你知道，对一些人来说，这就像你在商场的广播系统中听到的音乐。更严厉的，如果你能想象的话，是批评《宁静风暴》如此坚决地非政治化。对一些人来说，这对于像《宁静风暴》这样庞大且有影响力的黑人音乐形式来说是不寻常的。带着一丝讽刺，一位评论家甚至形容安妮塔·贝克说，非洲裔美国人已经成功进入中产阶级，就像我们只是要听这种柔和、自满的声音
music as a symbol of all we've achieved, but you know people who were still thinking we have a long way to go in terms of full equality and Quiet Storm feels sort of like a retreat from that. This was the 1980s, a moment when Black America and Black DC in particular was in the midst of multiple crises, especially with Reaganomics, crack cocaine, and the war on drugs. The way some listeners saw it, Black music had a responsibility to capture the urgency of the moment, but Quiet Storm seemed to be abdicating Black music's historic role as the teller of truths about the hard realities of black life in America.
音乐作为我们所取得一切成就的象征，但你知道，那些仍然认为我们在全面平等方面还有很长的路要走的人，觉得《宁静风暴》感觉像是一种退缩。这是20世纪80年代，一个美国黑人，特别是华盛顿黑人区，正处于多重危机之中的时刻，特别是里根经济学、快克可卡因和毒品战争。在一些听众看来，黑人音乐有责任捕捉当下的紧迫感，但《宁静风暴》似乎正在放弃黑人音乐作为美国黑人生活艰难现实真相讲述者的历史角色。
The last thing black folks needed was gushy love songs and apolitical music. It felt complacent, especially as Reagan took over, and especially as the opportunities for African Americans in the US started retreating back to a pre-civil rights era. And here was Quiet Storm just kind of encouraging people to be calm and stay home and be domestic and make money. Resentment was growing for Quiet Storm, which just felt more and more out of
黑人最不需要的就是多愁善感的情歌和非政治化的音乐。它感觉很自满，特别是在里根上台时，特别是在美国非洲裔美国人的机会开始退回到民权时代之前时。而《宁静风暴》只是在鼓励人们保持冷静、待在家里、变得居家并赚钱。对《宁静风暴》的怨恨正在增长，它感觉越来越脱离
touch. A new generation of artists and fans wanted something really different from black popular music. and fans wanted something really different from black popular music. When you look at the attitude when hip hop arrived as a force, a lot of what hip hop came to represent was antithetical to the quiet storm. This is music critic Nelson George again. The ideas about what is acceptable in black music at that time had gotten very conservative. Because now you're looking at a class of executives and radio programmers who are middle class, who are aspirational, who are cavassier drinkers, who are, you know, they play backgammon at the club.
现实。新一代艺术家和粉丝想要与黑人流行音乐截然不同的东西。当嘻哈作为一种力量出现时，你看看那种态度，嘻哈所代表的很多东西与《宁静风暴》是对立的。这是音乐评论家尼尔森·乔治再次发言。当时关于黑人音乐中什么是可接受的想法已经变得非常保守。因为现在你面对的是一群中产阶级、有抱负、喝着干邑、在俱乐部玩双陆棋的高管和广播节目编排者。
The gooey, apolitical, deeply unfunky sound of Quiet Storm had proven so successful that by the mid-1980s, it dictated what many major labels wanted from their Black artists. Record companies had locked in on so-called upscale urban audiences, and the gates were all but closed to Black music that didn't appeal to those listeners.
《宁静风暴》那种粘糊糊的、非政治化的、极其缺乏放克味的声音已经证明非常成功，以至于到80年代中期，它决定了许多大唱片公司对黑人艺术家的要求。唱片公司已经锁定了所谓的“高端城市受众”，而那些不吸引这些听众的黑人音乐的大门几乎被关闭了。
This was exactly when and why rap music, which was relatively new at the time, kicked in the door. This whole hip-hop thing, sneakers? We're wearing sneakers into the club? No, we're not wearing sneakers into the club. What Quiet Storm became part of was a calcification, and so things became more about the mainstream. We get these records and they all sounded
这正是说唱音乐（当时相对较新）踢开大门的时间和原因。整个嘻哈的东西，运动鞋？我们穿着运动鞋进俱乐部？不，我们不穿运动鞋进俱乐部。《宁静风暴》所成为的一部分是一种钙化，所以事情变得更多地关于主流。我们得到这些唱片，它们听起来都一样。
really shiny and glistening. Hip-hop comes in and begins to rebel against the smoothness. Even as hip-hop took off in the late 1980s, Quiet Storm Radio was still popular all over the country. Kathy Hughes, the station manager who first dreamed up The Quiet Storm Show, left WHUR decades ago and went on to start a giant media company. Melvin Lindsay, the original voice of The Quiet Storm,
非常闪亮且耀眼。嘻哈音乐随之兴起，开始反抗这种平滑感。即使在嘻哈音乐于 20 世纪 80 年代末腾飞时，“宁静风暴”电台（Quiet Storm Radio）在全国各地依然广受欢迎。凯西·休斯（Kathy Hughes）是最初构思出《宁静风暴》节目的电台经理，她几十年前离开了 WHUR，后来创办了一家大型媒体公司。梅尔文·林赛（Melvin Lindsay）是《宁静风暴》最初的声音，
left WHUR in 1985. And wow, I've got to take a deep breath before I do this. It's been nine years I've been here with The Quiet Storm at WHUR, and if you haven't heard by now, this is my last night. At midnight it's sign off and sign out. There are so many people to thank and so many people to thank. He was lured away by WKYS, another Black station serving DC, and a WHUR rival. As proof of Melvin's star power, WKYS offered him a historic million dollar multi-year contract to replicate his old show under the new name Melvin's Melodies. Melvin had a huge
于 1985 年离开了 WHUR。哇，在说这段话之前，我得深吸一口气。我在 WHUR 的《宁静风暴》节目已经待了九年了，如果你还没听说的话，这是我的最后一晚。午夜时分，节目就要结束，我也要告别了。有太多人要感谢，真的有太多人要感谢。他被 WKYS 挖走，那是另一家服务于华盛顿特区的黑人电台，也是 WHUR 的竞争对手。作为梅尔文明星号召力的证明，WKYS 为他提供了一份历史性的百万美元多年期合同，让他以新名字“梅尔文的旋律”（Melvin's Melodies）重现他以前的节目。梅尔文拥有巨大的
career in radio and TV around Washington. He was hosting a show on BET until he became too sick to work. Melvin died of AIDS in 1992. He was 36 years old. So young. Towards the end of his life, Melvin expressed a lot of gratitude for the love and support that he got from his fans. He was a local celebrity. People in DC loved him. Still do. Here he is in a phone interview not long before his death, talking about all the great food his supporters were sending to his bedside. Apple pie, lasagna, brownies. I mean, people just, I mean, unrealistic, fine things. The show does love.
在华盛顿的广播和电视事业。他曾主持过 BET 的一档节目，直到后来病重无法工作。梅尔文于 1992 年死于艾滋病。他年仅 36 岁。太年轻了。在生命临近结束时，梅尔文表达了对粉丝们给予的爱与支持的深切感激。他是一位当地名人。华盛顿特区的人们爱他。至今依然如此。这是他在去世前不久接受的一次电话采访，谈到了支持者们送到他床边的所有美食。苹果派、千层面、布朗尼。我的意思是，人们送来的东西，简直是，太不可思议了，太棒了。这个节目确实充满爱。
There are still Quiet Storm shows everywhere, like The Sweat Hotel, hosted by Quiet Storm legend Keith Sweat. WHUR still has its program, now called the original Quiet Storm. And hip-hop did not kill off the Quiet Storm sound. Actually, a lot of rappers, from a tribe called Quest, to Kendrick,rick to Drake have sampled or incorporated new and old school Quiet Storm into their music. On his song Doomsday, you can hear MF Doom's sample of Shaday, who was a Quiet Storm in today's R&B, stuff you maybe didn't realize was a continuation of the genre.
现在到处都有“宁静风暴”风格的节目，比如由“宁静风暴”传奇人物基思·斯威特（Keith Sweat）主持的《汗水酒店》（The Sweat Hotel）。WHUR 仍然保留着它的节目，现在改名为“原版宁静风暴”。嘻哈音乐并没有扼杀“宁静风暴”的声音。事实上，许多说唱歌手，从“部落呼唤探索”（A Tribe Called Quest）到肯德里克（Kendrick），再到德雷克（Drake），都曾采样或将新老派的“宁静风暴”融入到他们的音乐中。在他的歌曲《末日》（Doomsday）中，你可以听到 MF Doom 对莎黛（Sade）的采样，她就是“宁静风暴”风格的代表，在当今的 R&B 中，有些东西你可能没意识到是该流派的延续。
I'd say over the past 10 years, the kinds of music that even pitchfork hipsters are listening to, it owes a lot to the legacy of Quiet Storm. Stuff like Frank Ocean, stuff like Solange. This is music that is, again, it's not trying to wake up the neighbors and it's soul music, it's R&B music. This is music that is based in vibes, it's based in ambience. As I've worked on this story, almost every Black person I mentioned it to immediately recognized the quiet storm and knew something about the radio show. Across a range of ages, from all over the U.S., even folks born well after Melvin Lindsay passed.
我想说，在过去 10 年里，即使是 Pitchfork 网站上的那些时髦人士所听的音乐，很大程度上也归功于“宁静风暴”的遗产。比如弗兰克·奥申（Frank Ocean）的作品，索兰格（Solange）的作品。这些音乐再次强调，它不是为了吵醒邻居，它是灵魂乐，是 R&B 音乐。这种音乐基于氛围，基于环境感。在我制作这个故事的过程中，我提到的几乎每一个黑人都立刻认出了“宁静风暴”，并对这个广播节目有所了解。跨越不同年龄段，来自美国各地，甚至包括那些在梅尔文·林赛去世后很久才出生的人。
The story of Quiet Storm is that this is a genre of music really championed by Black folks. And during its heyday, it mostly stays within Black communities. This is ethnomusicologist Fredera Hadley again. And that doesn't mean like, oh, no one can come in and participate. But I think if one is going to talk about Quiet Storm, that's one of the genres that
“宁静风暴”的故事在于，这是一种真正由黑人倡导的音乐流派。在它的鼎盛时期，它主要保留在黑人社区内。这是民族音乐学家弗雷德拉·哈德利（Fredera Hadley）再次强调的。这并不意味着，哦，没有人可以参与进来。但我认为，如果有人要谈论“宁静风暴”，那是其中一种
demands that you center Black love, Black emotions. It's not about marching. It's not about being on Soul Train, like all these very kind of broadly visible things. It's about Black intimacy. And I think that's part of what makes so much of the story, A Quiet Storm, important. It's something that black people name, created, and maintain for themselves.
要求你以黑人的爱、黑人的情感为中心的流派。它不是关于游行。它不是关于登上《灵魂列车》（Soul Train），不像所有这些非常广泛可见的事物。它是关于黑人的亲密关系。我认为这正是让“宁静风暴”的故事如此重要的部分原因。这是黑人自己命名、创造并为自己维护的东西。
The Grammy winner for Marvin Gaye, that's Sexual Healing. Before that, from the album I Want You, we heard Come Live With Me, Angel. It's 852 in Washington. You're in tune to the Quiet Storm. 99% Invisible was produced this week by me, Christopher Johnson, and edited by Vivian Lay. This episode was mixed by Martin Gonzalez, with music by Swan Royale, Jamila Sandotto,
马文·盖伊（Marvin Gaye）的格莱美获奖作品，那是《性疗法》（Sexual Healing）。在此之前，来自专辑《我想要你》（I Want You），我们听到了《来和我一起生活，天使》（Come Live With Me, Angel）。华盛顿时间 8 点 52 分。你正在收听的是《宁静风暴》。本周的《99% 无形》（99% Invisible）由我克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）制作，薇薇安·莱（Vivian Lay）编辑。本集由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音，音乐由天鹅皇家（Swan Royale）、贾米拉·桑多托（Jamila Sandotto）提供，
and George Langford. Fact-checking by Nidia Bautista. Special thanks to Nelson George, who's working on a very cool new documentary. It's called A Great Day in Hip Hop, The Film. There's a link on our website. Go check it out, show your love and support. Special thanks also to the Black Radio,
以及乔治·兰福德（George Langford）。事实核查由尼迪亚·包蒂斯塔（Nidia Bautista）完成。特别感谢尼尔森·乔治（Nelson George），他正在制作一部非常酷的新纪录片。片名叫《嘻哈伟大的一天：电影》（A Great Day in Hip Hop, The Film）。我们的网站上有链接。去看看吧，表达你的爱与支持。还要特别感谢黑人广播，
Telling It Like It Was collection at the Indiana University Archives of African American Music and Culture. Also, 99PI is throwing a Quiet Storm party. DJ Ayanna Heaven will be spending slow jam classics from the 70s and 80s and it's all going down Sunday July 27th in downtown Brooklyn and it's free. Check out our website and socials for more info And if you're local or in town come through Kathy to is our executive producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director
印第安纳大学非裔美国人音乐与文化档案馆的“讲述过去”（Telling It Like It Was）收藏。此外，99PI 正在举办一场“宁静风暴”派对。DJ 阿亚娜·天堂（Ayanna Heaven）将播放 70 年代和 80 年代的慢摇经典，活动将于 7 月 27 日星期日在布鲁克林市中心举行，而且是免费的。查看我们的网站和社交媒体了解更多信息。如果你在当地或在城里，一定要来。凯西·托（Kathy To）是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。
The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei Jason de Leon Emmett Fitzgerald Delaney Hall Lasha Madon Kelly Prime Joe Rosenberg Jacob Medina Gleason, and the boss, Roman Mars. He'll be back next week. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, and this episode was produced in beautiful Brooklyn, New York. You can find us on Blue Sky,
团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barubei）、杰森·德·莱昂（Jason de Leon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、拉莎·马登（Lasha Madon）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason），以及老板罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。他下周会回来。《99% 无形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作的。我们是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一员，本集是在美丽的纽约布鲁克林制作的。你可以在 Blue Sky 上找到我们，
as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99% Invisible at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器。那里有链接，还有《99% 无形》的每一集往期节目，网址是 99pi.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。